MARK BEISSINGER:
So Global Seminars
is a small group experiential
learning course offered
by Princeton, by the Princeton
Institute for International
and Regional Studies.
We take a small group
of Princeton students
to a location around
the world, teach them
a course on a topic
in that place,
have them interact
with the subjects
that they're learning
about in the classroom.
So they go out to
sites that they're
learning about in
the classroom, maybe
they visit an ancient
site or a museum.
They have experts come
into the classroom who
tell them about the
various aspects of what
they're learning.
These are things that they can't
do on the Princeton campus.
So they have this
experiential element.
VICTORIA SEYOUM:
It was definitely
one of the highlights of
my Princeton experience.
We were able to be in class
and discuss the Roman ghettos.
And then hours
later, we would be
walking through the
Roman ghettos, actually,
there is real time.
So I think that sort of learning
experience is very unique.
And it's something
that I'm really
grateful that I had the
opportunity to be a part of.
MAYA WAHRMAN:
Well, I think being
able to take a class on a
place while you're there
for the time is really
invaluable, because even little
cultural interactions
that-- especially,
because we were kind of an
anthropology based seminar--
that we're learning about.
We're reading about how men and
women interact in public, how
people treat their children,
and then you go to the market
and you see that.
AVANEESH NARLA: I think
the best part of it
was that we were so immersed
in the entire experience.
And we had this
group of people who
came from a diversity
of academic interest.
I studied something
else and other people
studied economics and so forth.
All of us shared a
passion for a language,
and this emotion really helped
us understand language better
and how it plays an important
role in each other lives.
GHITA GUESSOUS: As
a science major,
I don't get to think about
a lot of the philosophical
implications of modern things.
And photography's a
very modern technology.
And it was very
valuable for me to be
able to think for an
extended period of time
about all these themes,
about how photography relates
to things like appearances,
and death, and life, and light,
and shadows, and all of these
dichotomies in everyday life
MARK BEISSINGER: So all
of the global seminars
are faculty driven
in the sense that we
go to places that the
faculty know about,
are experts about
where they want to go.
The people that we have
teaching these seminars
are some of the
world's leading experts
on those particular societies.
ZACH RUCHMAN: The
relationship that I developed
with the professor to say
served as a mentor for me
throughout my entire Princeton
career, and he continues too.
I still see him when
I'm in New York.
We grab drinks.
We grab dinner.
It was much easier to
develop that relationship
on that seminar when we were
all together for six weeks
than it would have been
on campus when there
were so many distractions
and there were so
many things to do.
And being in one
place for six weeks
and just focusing on
one subject really
allowed that
relationship to develop.
MARK BEISSINGER:
What stands out most
are the experiences
that students have,
and those are things that
they just don't forget.
The ways in which they've
connected with society, just
the things that they've seen,
the kind of learning that
takes place, they praise
that over and over again.
MAYA WAHRMAN: What the
Global Seminar does
is you are there specifically
for the purpose of being there
and for soaking in that place.
And I would say you should
do a Global Seminar.
If you're thinking about
it, go to the place
that excites you
most, that would maybe
be hardest for you get to.
Try all the foods.
Really try to kind of
get in deep, I would say.
[MUSIC PLAYING]